hey this is presto Walker a square is
inscribed in a circle a smaller square
is drawn the smaller square shares aside
with the inscribed square and its other
two corners touch the circle what is the
ratio of the large squares area to the
small squares area
I found this problem online and the
person who shared it said it was asked
during a job interview I gave it a try
and I could not figure it out but it's
an interesting problem and I thought to
share it because perhaps you could solve
it so can you figure it out give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution
let's first focus on the inscribed
square we'll draw a diameter of the
circle that's equal to 2 times the
radius that connects two corners of the
square the size of the square and the
diameter form an isosceles right
triangle so we can solve for the large
square side length as equaling 2 R
divided by square root of 2 this
simplifies to be R square root of 2 now
let's return to the small square how can
we figure out its side length we're
going to draw a couple of line segments
well first draw the radius of the circle
with length R to a corner of the small
circle next we will drop a perpendicular
from the center of the circle to the
bottom side of the small square this
will bisect the chord of the small
square so now we need to figure out some
lengths of this triangle that we've just
drawn right s for the small squares side
lengths the other leg of the triangle
will be s over 2 because it's equal to
1/2 of the small square side the
remaining length will be 1/2 of the
larger square side
this will be our square root of 2/2 so
now we have a right triangle and we know
all of the lengths so let's just focus
on this triangle we're going to use the
Pythagorean theorem we have the sum of
the squares of the lengths of the legs
will be equal to the square of the
hypotenuse we can simplify this equation
and we know that R is an unknown
constant so we'll treat this as a
polynomial in s we'll multiply this by 4
and now we have a quadratic in s and if
you think creatively you can actually
factor this out so we have two different
terms and the product of them will be
equal to 0 so one of these terms or both
of them have to be equal to 0 so we end
up with two possible solutions X is
equal to R square root of 2 divided by 5
or s is equal to negative R times the
square root of 2 the problem with the
second solution is that that would lead
to a negative number for s and we know
that X has to be a positive number
because it's a side length so we can
exclude this second solution so we now
figured out s in terms of R so now let's
return to our main diagram
so now let's just focus on the two
things we figured out we figured out the
length of the large square side and we
figured out the length of the small
square size and both of these are in
terms of the radius R if you compare
these two numbers will see that the
large square side length is five times
as large as the smaller square sidelines
since area is proportional to side
length squared we can then conclude the
large squares area is equal to 5 squared
which equals 25 times as large as the
small square and that's our answer the
large square is 25 times larger than the
small square did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch
around my blog mind your decisions that
you can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can catch it on social media
at pressure Walker and if you liked this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description